قصتي عن النظرية السخيفة هي
قصة عن الأشخاص الذين يعيشون في هذه
الضوابط الحكومية فقاعة كل
موظفينا يعملون في غسيل دماغ من قبل
دعاية الدولة إذا كانت هناك
صورة للمسيح يتم
التحكم في أشياء مثل صورته بنفسك في المرة الأولى التي أتت
هناك ، كان عام 2015  لقد مرت سنتان
منذ الاحتجاجات وأعمال الحرب الأهلية ،
ما كان يذهلنا طوال الوقت
أنه قد يكون هناك انفجار فقط في
الكتلة التالية وعلى الجانب الآخر
من الشارع ، مما يؤدي إلى ضجة عمل عادية
وازدحام مروري و  سيغادر الناس بشكل
طبيعي ، أعتقد أنني قد أكون
أحد آخر الصحفيين الغربيين الذين
يحاربون البوليمر قبل أن تلتقطها إيزيس ، لذا
احتفظ بهذه الصورة في شقتي لأن
هذا تراثنا الذي لم يتم
تدميره ، يمكنك رؤيته هنا يمكنك
رؤيته في  يتخلل المجتمع
حتى يكون لديهم صراع قوي على الرغم
من أنه ليس مجرد أرض جميلة
ولديهم ثقافة غنية جدًا وأنا
آسف حقًا لأنهم يدمرون
ذلك بأعلى مستويات